- Yeah, if we talk about today Mark,
I've been speaking a little bit about,
I spoke a little bit about the good side
of being a gang member.
I spoke a little bit about,
in the other ones about the bad
side of being a gang member,
I spoke about being set up by women,
I spoke about, a little bit about prison,
you know what I mean,
as much as I could put out there.
Today I wanna speak about
mainly me and my family,
where I come from and what they're about.
You know what I mean?
How they came about in my hood.
How deep they were at one time,
how deep we were all
together when we're all like,
just that age where
everybody was in other words,
messing around, you
know, well, first of all,
I think my first memories
of the gang thing was,
I remember my father was
watching the news one time
and he went to, he was on,
it was "Eyewitness News,"
and I looked, and I see my
grandmother on the news,
my uncles, you know what I mean?
A couple of my homies, older
homies, and I was like,
what's my grandma doing on the news?
What's she doing?
Well, at that time, my grandmother,
she was out there running
around in different hoods.
There was a lotta gang wrangles going on
and what they were forming was
they were forming some type
of a thing that was called United Parents.
They were like, all the gang
members' parents would get
together and they had a softball league
and they used to sell,
snow cones and hot dogs,
you know what I mean? But
it was all, gang related.
It was all, everybody had to
be gang affiliation to do that.
And I remember, my sister and brother,
they used to be a little older than me
and my little brother.
So I used to see 'em
get up and get dressed.
And I knew exactly where they were going.
And I used to remember, man, I can't wait.
I can't wait so I can wear
my pants, like my brother,
or sit there and iron my pants for hours
like my brother, and listen
to oldies while I'm ironing
and shit like that and the homies calling,
and he's talking to homies
and then he's telling
you my homie stories,
I'm listening to the
stories about him telling,
and I'm looking at my brother, like,
he's like Superman and all
the stories he told me,
he never got punched and he
always used to be the guy
who breaks somebody off.
And, I had to seen my brother in action
before I really realized
that yeah, he was that guy.
I didn't even really wanna
talk for the simple fact
that we just don't come to common ground,
we just can't get on common ground,
ever since I beat him up and I was like 15
and I beat him up ever
since he can't accept it.
So, he always wants to
fight and beat me up
and I think I'm just gonna allow him
to whoop my ass one good time
and then maybe he'll
stop, but I don't know.
But I used to watch him
and my brother used to
wear pinstripes Zoot suit.
He used the word, Charlie
Browns, Hush Puppies.
He used to wear wing tips,
you know what I mean?
Everything, he used
to, Friskos, Ben Davis,
Pendletons, flannels, he used
the wear London fog coats.
I knew wat everything was
called, you know what I mean?
So, where the girls used to wear tube tops
and then they wore Daisy
Dukes back at that time,
they were like Jordan's jeans,
he used to wear, the black,
they were like black,
what can I call them,
like rubber bands, they used
to put 'em on their fingers
you know what I mean, and cross
'em, you know what I mean?
They always had a little
tattoo either across
or a dot or three dots.
They used to wear their
hair real high like an M
and I remember, I used to see my sister,
and she was one of my finest
home girls at her time.
I think she was the finest at that time.
But a lotta dudes were on her.
I used to see my homies on her and shit,
you know what I mean, and
I used to hear stories
about her and my brother, I'm like,
my aunt, she used to call from
the hood and call my father
and tell my father, "Hey,
your daughter's over here,
all PCP'd out, and I'd go with my father
in the car and I'll see
my sister PCP'd out.
I don't know where she's
at, you know what I mean?
She's holding on to a fan.
She's been there like three hours.
You know, I never heard
my dad tell her anything,
to tell you the truth.
My dad was like somebody that I am today,
I don't lie to my kids.
I tell my kids, everything I do,
not bad, bad shit but I
mean, I don't hide nothing
from 'em because I don't want
someone else to tell them.
And then they asked me and then they turn
around and tell me, well, why did you lie?
Why couldn't you just tell me?
So I'm pretty upfront with my kids
and that's the way my father was?
'Cause he used to go get my sister
and she'd be man, all angel dust out.
I'm talking about back
then the angel dust,
it'd make you do some crazy
shit, you know what I mean?
And it was called kukui dust,
they call it the kukui dust,
I remember it's only $10 for
a little tinfoil folded up,
you got about three joints out of there
but it was good shit.
And when I see that, I was like, oh man,
I seem one of my uncles sling it.
And I seen the big old
stack of money he had.
I was like, oh man, I can't
wait 'til I get that age.
And I'm gonna cook me
up some like he does,
'cause I watched him
and he didn't teach me.
I actually watched him where,
when I became like 13,
14, I cooked my own shit,
I get my own leaves, get my own juice,
with the refrigerator,
and I'll do my thing and
cook me up some angel dust.
I'd take it to the parties.
And I rolled about 10 joints
and have 10 angels dust joints.
And I was fucking up, but I'd just do it.
I'd send the joints in there
and everybody's smoking
and then I'll slip a couple
of angel dust joints in there,
you know what I mean?
I'd see some of the people be like,
(inhaling)
"What is this?"
And I've also new kinds of weed,
and some new shit that
came over the season.
I gave 'em some bullshit ass story.
The next thing you know,
man, they're all fucked up,
they don't know what to do,
they don't know where
to go, they're parked
in the front of the house with your car,
for fucking four, five
hours, their money's gone.
Everything's gone already,
everybody walked away
with everything because
there's so PCP'd out
that I would see this all the time.
I would see my homegirls
and homeboys in the front
of my grandmother's house
when we'd go over and visit.
I mean, there'd be like 20 of
them, you know what I mean?
15, 20 of them.
And they're all, they
got guns, they got drugs,
they got dope and they
weren't hiding anything.
So, I remember, me and my
other cousin, we used to play,
you know what I mean, and
we used play gangsters,
nobody was a cop, you know what I mean?
And I was like, whoa, what the fuck?
There was some, when I used to grow up,
I seen things, I seen kids
that wanted to be cops.
Not one family member of
mine wanted to be a cop,
not one, you know what I mean?
It wasn't gonna happen.
And then, and that's kind of odd
because always in the family
there's somebody that is law enforcement
and not one of my family
members is in law enforcement.
I think the closest thing
to it is one's a lawyer and
one's a border patrol agent
but no cops, man, no cops,
and I used to trip out,
'cause I had a lotta cousins
and we're all younger.
Who do you wanna be, who do
you wanna be, who do you wanna?
Everybody wanted to be a gangster.
A cholo, everybody wanted to be a cholo.
So, in my head, in my thoughts
I knew where I was going.
I knew exactly what was gonna happen
and how it was gonna go down
and I remember when I broke
the cycle with my grandmother,
'cause she was on me,
"No you're not gonna be
from the hood", and, "No,
you can do something else."
And I was telling her
grandma, come on, man,
it's coming, it's coming and she's been,
"Oh, just won't you to do something else."
And I was like, nah,
I already knew what I was destined to be.
I already knew what was gonna happen.
I knew I wasn't gonna get
jumped in, I knew that,
you know what I mean?
I also knew that I was gonna jump a gang
of motherfuckers in, I knew that.
And as I was growing up,
and I watched my uncles do their thing,
I used to just copy exactly what they did.
If they were selling bud,
I'd watch him put the buddy baggies,
how much they would put in there,
I'd watch where they get, where
they go buy the baggies at,
you know what I mean?
I'd even watch what homie's
giving them the bud,
you know what I mean, 'cause
I want, as soon as I got,
I was about 11, 12, but
as soon as I got like 14,
15 year old, I was gonna
take over the operation.
I was just gonna take it over.
And if my uncle got mad, oh well,
I did it to him, you know what I mean?
After I got of age, they
had it caught going on
and I just stepped right in there,
And when I stepped right in
there, I took it over, man.
I was maybe like, maybe 16.
And I hear a lotta dudes
tell stories about, oh yeah,
when I was 15, 16, I had my own house.
And I'm gonna tell you
when I was 16 years,
I had my own house.
I wasn't buying or anything
but I was paying $1,300 rent
and I was only 16 years old,
And I just remember people used to come
over and ask whose house it was
and how they said, it's mine.
And those people would
give me a look like,
what the fuck's up with this kid,
'cause I was really young,
maybe a little facial hair,
but my house was fairly nice.
We're talking about French windows,
patio deck, all that good shit,
big old garage, you know what I mean,
just a fucking nice ass pad.
Big old front yard.
And I remember the looks
people used to give,
they were all different.
I remember the one my
mother-in-law gave me.
She gave me a look like, man, you,
you're fucking too much, man.
'Cause she knew what was going
on, you know what I mean?
She knew that I had a gang
of homies living in there,
you know what I mean, used
to be like seven guys,
seven girls living in my house,
all my homies and homegirls,
we used to live in there,
man, you know what I mean?
And I was only, sorry about
that, I was only 16, man.
And I was paying the
rent, getting it paid,
you know what I mean?
Or a car, I didn't really trip on a car,
'cause my uncles and aunts, they had cars,
and I'd take off in their
shit, they'd get mad
but I mean, fuck, I only
drove around the park,
you know what I mean, and that
was a big thing in my hood,
the park, it's called Nettles Park.
it's got a name of another hood
but it's our park,
and I remember, when I was younger,
I used to go play in the park
and I used to watch my
homies playing horse shoes
and sitting, drinking and shit.
And I was like, man, I used
to tell my cousins, man,
I can't wait to go over there,
I can't wait to have a car
like that or I can't wait
to carry a gun like him.
And I'd see here my
cousins run by real young,
and they go, oh, I'm doing a drive-by.
And I used to be like, oh my God,
my little cousin, like eight,
seven years old talking
about he's doing a drive-by,
and man, I was like, fuck,
he was following in mine and my cousins'
that are my age footsteps,
and they were the next ones coming,
And I was like, fuck, it's just a cycle.
I was like the third, fourth
cycle, they're the fifth one,
and when I hear stuff
like that running by me,
they'd be like, I'ma
shoot you, I'ma get you,
I'ma do a drive-by, like, oh my God,
what this little boy saying?
I'ma a drive-by, no kid,
that's not what you're supposed to do,
But it, they had it in their head,
that the drive-by was okay
because so many people
were doing them, I guess,
kids looked at it like,
whoa, that was something
really big, and to me it wasn't
shit, you know what I mean?
Hey, we could drive by and
fucking unload two clips
and hit the wrong house, come
on, you know what I mean?
Anybody could do that,
you know what I'm saying?
They say any punk can pull
the trigger, I believe that.
But then again,
a couple guys I seen get
caught behind the trigger
and they pull shit, you know what I mean?
You know what happened
is, some people have it,
some people don't,
and everybody's different,
you know what I mean?
Everybody's different, I
used to watch my homies
that got in the hood when
they were like 15, 16,
and I was already 15, 16,
but I already had been
from the hood like five years,
and these dudes are barely getting in.
I've seen 'em go from one person
and turn into somebody totally different,
and not anybody bad, but just somebody
that took this guy off the streets,
there was one dude that
he's my homeboy now,
and I remember I did something
and he was in the backseat,
and you that play the game
know what I'm talking about.
He was in the backseat
and that wasn't right,
it wasn't supposed to go down like that.
And I remember, I thought, man, you know,
poor guy, he's the wrong
place at the wrong time.
He shoulda just, figured
he was still asleep.
I guess he was asleep in
the backseat or something.
But I remember, man, I told my homie like,
and my homie's like, "Nah,
man, what're you talking about,
I'm an old friend."
I'm like,
(Johnny scoffs)
I don't know, I think
he's your friend, uh-uh,
ain't my friend, and my homie
talked me out of it, man.
and he had pushed me away
and shit, and he left him.
Lo and behold, man went to prison,
got out and walked in the room
and my homeboy was sitting
right there, man, the same guy
that I was gonna, you know,
probably harm him to the fullest,
and then wasn't gonna have
a second thought about it.
I couldn't have him
there, but I see him now
and I see, when I see the
first time I smiled at him,
and he's, I ain't saying we're like that
'cause he was there and
he's my little homie now,
and I should tell you, 'cause
he, shit like that happens.
Some of the guys that I
knew went to school with me,
and good friends of mine, man.
I was sitting there on the other side,
I see him flipping me off and shit.
I'm like, wow, you know, and damn,
school you were cool as fuck, you know.
Now you went to your side
and you wanna act like
a dickhead, it's okay.
I'll ended up catching them,
beating them up anyways.
And that was another thing,
they pushed on my family,
to come for these,
with these, and we used to do that a lot.
A lotta my cousins and
brothers, we fight a lot
of people, and beat up a lotta people,
and we used to just be normal
to beat motherfuckers up
just beat 'em up, and that was it.
And it felt pretty good, you
know, when you shoot somebody,
you can't really feel nothing
because can't go around and brag about it.
When you beat somebody up
everybody knows you beat him up,
so, you got kind of more,
a little bit more stripes
than actually shooting somebody.
'Cause you shoot somebody,
you won't say, shit,
but you beat somebody up, you can say,
oh yeah, I beat that fool up.
There's a lotta dudes I see,
on the streets and shit I beat up before,
I don't hold no grudges or nothing,
but I was just talking about my family
because we're so
intertwined in the gang life
that there was no calling cops,
there's no telling,
if the cop ask you, you
just shut the fuck up,
No name, nothing, nothing,
you tell 'em shit.
My grandmother still, they still say shit,
and that's what we did.
I'd say shit, and that was as
still as young kids, and man,
'cause you would just, you
would just your average mom
and father, trying to tell your kids,
hey, don't you ever tell, don't be a rat
and you're a kid, I'm like, goddamn,
I already knew what a rat was,
I already knew what snitching was
at a young, young age and I
was put under a microscope,
you know what I mean?
Like, boom, he's gonna be a gang member
and we're gonna do just like this,
and they led me through
it, you know what I mean?
And it was a rough road.
It was a rough fucking road.
I shared a lotta shit on these channels,
a lotta shit, and I still
have a lot more shit to share,
you know what I mean?
But I just wanted to give
you a little something
about myself, about me, the lifestyle
that I really didn't
have a choice to choose.
Some people say I did, but nah,
'cause I didn't wanna be the
only one that wasn't rolling
with my cousins and my brothers,
they're all gang members,
they're going for a gang fight
and I'ma sit back and just kick it,
stay back with the women
and children who are safe?
Nah, I don't wanna be that guy.
So, I jumped right in
and I remember my grandfather,
he didn't know, man,
for a long time, he didn't know, man,
and when he found out, ah
man, it broke his heart,
I was fucked up, but you know,
he knew that it was bound
to take place eventually.
I got everybody, cousins, everything, man.
They're all pulling from every direction,
and when you got cousins in
and you're from the hood,
and there's like 10 of you,
you could move mountains
like that, man, shit gets done.
You're not worried about
your cousin running on you.
'Cause if he runs on you,
back home he's gonna
get his ass fucked up,
So he's not gonna run.
I used to hate it when me
and my cousin get caught.
You know what I mean, by bigger fools
and I'm running, fuck 'em,
you know what I mean, I'm running.
I'll run and my cousins get caught,
but I could go back from this
shit, but I used to hate that
to be honest with you,
you know what I mean?
We can outrun these guys,
you don't wanna run,
'cause you want to to fight, I
gotta stay and fight for you,
I don't wanna get beat
up big old motherfuckers,
but I had to stay or I will get beat up,
you know what I mean, and
that was another part of life,
'cause being a gang member, you
whole family, you know that,
you don't leave nobody behind
you get beat the fuck up
when you get home, you know,
and, you'd get really beat up,
beat up bad, everybody's gonna watch
and they won't say shit, you know?
No, leave him alone, that's too much.
No, none of that.
They just watch you gat your ass whipped.
And that's another thing
with living the gang life
and having family in the
gang life saying you know,
growing up in my family, as I
watched everybody get older,
and some go to jail, some
would have terrible accidents,
like get stabbed and
shot, different things,
those were the only things
that kind of stopped me
from moving so quick was,
fuck, i'ma have to get shot,
I'ma have to go to jail.
Wow, you gotta do all that.
And all that happened, it all happened,
it all took place, and some
of the things I was like,
ah, I couldn't, you know,
I couldn't stomach 'em,
I'm like, man, shit, I'ma
have to go through this.
And my nephew just recently shared
with me that he went to prison,
and I didn't even know, I
didn't even know and you know,
what he told me, this is
exactly what he told me.
He said, when he went to
prison he had never been
in jail before, he went
straight to prison.
First time and people, he
said, well, you gotta be safe.
So he was sitting there for like a month.
He started stressing real hard.
And then he said, nah, fuck that.
You know, if my uncle Johnny could do it,
and my uncle Ruben could do it
and my cousin, louis
could do it, I can do it.
Damn, when he told me that, I was like,
oh my God, you know what
mean, what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
Where does, where's that come from?
He felt that he could do the time
just because we've all did time.
So he's built for that.
He's breaded for that.
He's cut from that certain cloth,
that's what we're told,
you know, we're fucking,
he last of a dying breed, but we're cut
from a certain cloth that you were
just a little bit different
and it's okay to be different.
But when he told me that, he told me
that recently and it fucking,
it kinda took me for a spin
because he actually
trained his mind to do time
just by his uncles doing time,
And he knew we're doing years,
he went and did two years in it.
Well, he knew we did over
five a couple of times.
And, but he said, that's
where he motivated himself.
He used me, my past experience
and my brother's past experiences
and my cousins to motivate himself.
So that he can do his time,
and in a way that's good,
but in many other ways, oh, that's bad.
That's really bad
because anybody thinks, well,
I'll go to prison again.
Oh, well, so what?
You can't have that attitude.
I don't have that attitude.
I don't, I'm not looking
to go to jail ever again.
I'm never looking to be
handcuffed ever again
if I got the chance, you know?
I don't want them
touching me, searching me.
I wanna be where I tell
you, hey, wait up, man,
you don't need to touch
me, you know what I mean?
Straight up, you know what I mean?
I want it to be like that.
When it's like that I'll be content.
But other than that,
like I said, I got a hat
that says "Fuck The Police",
and I wear it a lot.
you know what I mean?
I get a lotta dirty looks.
The other day there was one
looking at me and I'm like,
what the fuck is he staring at?
I didn't realize I had
"Fuck The Police" on my hat.
You know what I mean?
And he's just staring at me, he's a young,
he's a little motherfucker,
he's wearing like about 10, soaking wet.
He's gonna do nothing,
put a handcuff on me.
Well, he was staring and I was like
what the fuck is this
fucking cop staring at?
And then I remembered, I had
"Fuck The Police" written
across my hat and cost
me $35 to get that hat.
But, I wanted to share
that today with you, Mark,
you know, I'll share more.
I wanna to, you know, go
into a few other things.
You know what I mean,
like, with my homegirls,
the way next time when I
explain it, I'm gonna explain
more or less about
how I was out there pushing shit
and I had to put women with me.
I couldn't trust my homeboys.
I couldn't trust a man, a woman, oh yeah.
You can trust them a lot more than a man.
And they're gonna give you your money.
I wanna share that next
time I come in with you,
and share that about how,
'cause I know you got some women
that told your stories.
I got some homegirls that
I can tell you stories
about me and them and they
all went to jail for me.
It's kind of hard to make a woman do time
but I wanna share that with you, Mark,
next time I come, you know?
- All right, Johnny.
- All right, bud.
- Great.
- Yeah.